Which whole numbers will make
this statement true?
We have the statement here where
we have some brackets
are less than 7.
So we just have to figure out
which whole numbers, if we put
them here, are really
less than 7.
So let's draw a number line
and let's go up to 7.
When we talk about whole
numbers, we're talking about
the non-negative numbers or
numbers that start at zero,
and they aren't fractions.
Let me draw them on
a number line.
Let's say we have this number
line right here.
We'll start at 0.
You could go below 0.
There are negative numbers, but
we're not going to concern
ourselves with them right now.
So you have 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7-- I'll go up a little
bit-- 8, 9.
Now we want all of the numbers
that are less than 7.
That's what that means.
We could write it like this.
Question mark is less than
7, and what would satisfy
question mark?
The hardest thing about these
greater than or less than is
remembering what the
symbol means.
We have the smaller side
pointing to the question mark,
so that is the smaller number.
We have the larger side of the
symbol pointing to the 7, so 7
is going to be the larger
of the two numbers.
So what numbers satisfy that?
Well, anything below 7.
Any whole number below 7.
So if we look at 7 on the number
line, what are all of
the whole numbers that are below
7, that are less than 7?
Well, we have a 6, we have 5,
we have 4, 3, 2, 1 or 0.
So you could put any of these
numbers here and the statement
would be true.
You could write 0
is less than 7.
That's true.
You could write 3
is less than 7.
That's true.
You could write 6 is less than
7, and that would be true.
You could not write that 8 is
less than 7, so 8 would not
satisfy this.
This is not true.
This is not true, so we
cannot write that.
8 is greater than 7.